there are plenty of character beats and
plot twists in fast X to keep fans
interested but the real selling point of
a fast and furious movie is the
absolutely outlandish action fastx had
so many unbelievable moments we had to
rank them
in F9 we meet Dom toretto's disowned
Flesh and Blood Brother Jacob which is
an admittedly weird story choice for a
series centered around the concept of
family fortunately John Cena more than
held his own in F9 as Jacob both as a
cunning antagonist and as a Soulful
tragic figure who gains Redemption and
rejoins the fast family unfortunately
unlike in F9 Cena doesn't get to do a
lot of hand-to-hand combat in fast X
despite Cena's obviously intimidating
size background in pro wrestling and
important role in the sequel for the
most part he's relegated to a car or a
spy plane luckily there is one glorious
scene of Jacob kicking butt and taking
names in the film it's towards the
beginning when the agency is tasked with
taking in Dom's family including his son
that's when Jacob swings into action
throwing and shooting agency goons
around the house to protect the
torrettos
this entire sequence culminates with an
amazing shot of Jacob doing Cena's
signature wrestling finish the attitude
adjustment to send a corrupt agency goon
through the floor as the camera follows
the downed agent
from the character's outsized
personalities to the blaring
melodramatic dance music score to the
saturated and constantly roving
cinematography fast X runs on all
cylinders even when something isn't
crashing or blowing up in most movies a
scene in which John Cena blows up a
bunch of bad guys with a cannon car
would be the most over-the-top moment
but fast X is not most movies it begins
with Jacob and Little Brian meeting at a
secret underground Rendezvous point to
meet up with dom that's where they pick
up the Canon car prototype Jacob has
been working on unfortunately bad guys
show up instead and Jacob has to drive
Little Brian in the cannon car to escape
Jacob then proceeds to blow the enemy
cars away with massive GI Joe style side
mounted cannons while Little Brian looks
on gleefully while that may not be the
healthiest response to seeing fiery
death a child could express at least
he's having fun
not very many people stay dead in the
Fast and Furious saga the arguably most
impactful death on Dom's team that of
Han was reversed in F9 tej Roman and
Ramsay even had an entire subplot in
that movie debating if they are all
impervious to harm a U2 may be
suggesting that we're what
invincible
[Music]
Maybe
however since the main series is said to
be ending soon some deaths might be more
permanent there's less road so to speak
to bring them back this means that For
Better or Worse Jacob toretto's
explosive sacrifice might actually stick
after Dante kidnaps Little Brian and Dom
and Jacob are in hot Pursuits Dominus
classic black Dodge Charger and Jacob
and his makeshift Cannon car however
Dante is surrounded by enemy vehicles
and Jacob's fuel line is cut so he can't
keep up he then decides to turn the
Cannons on his car toward the street and
use the force of their blasts to propel
him into the enemy cars blowing himself
up along with all the villains except
Dante allowing Dom to catch up to his
nemesis
ever since Fast Five the Fast and
Furious films have become a spy action
franchise and don't necessarily have a
ton to do with street racing but even
the later sequels in the series have
tried to shoehorn racing into the plot
somehow for instance there's the street
race in Cuba in the beginning of fate of
the Furious in fast X the obligatory
street race actually has some deadly
Stakes Dom goes to Brazil to meet up
with Diogo a Brazilian street racer
introduced in Fast Five
car
for car
Dante and his criminal Thug show up and
Diego protects Dom from Dante as his
crew outguns Dante's Posse Dante then
proposes a street race to alleviate the
standoff Daniela melchiorz Isabella who
we find out is the sister of Elena the
mother of Little Brian also joins the
race but not everything is as it seems
apparently Dante has rigged bombs on
Diogo and Isabel's cars to make Dom
choose who lives or dies Dom ends up
choosing to save Isabel and Diogo blows
up in a burst of flames Dom also ends up
losing the race to Dante though that's a
secondary consideration by that point
fast X begins during the events of
2011's Fast Five there's a remix of that
film's famous heist in which Dom and
Brian Drag The Vault containing hundreds
of millions of dollars of the Reyes
crime family's money with their cars
this time though we see the events
Through The Eyes of Jason momoa's
diabolical Dante Reyes in the chase
Dante is knocked into the water more
than a decade later near the end of fast
X Dom is captured by the agency in Rio
de Janeiro Dante and his army of
mercenaries then attacked Dom and the
Agents an explosive firefight ensues on
the same bridge where the finale of Fast
Five took place literally Bridging the
two films
Ames the acting head of the agency
seemingly becomes an ally to Dom as they
fight Dante's mercenaries together at
one point Dom uses a car door as a
bulletproof Shield Tess the daughter of
Mr Nobody even shows up and gets into
the fight before getting shot by a
sniper and miraculously surviving which
is itself pretty badass
Charlize Theron's vicious villain Cipher
first appeared in 2017's the fate of the
Furious in that film it's revealed that
she's pretty much been The Mastermind
behind all of the other Fast and Furious
villains since Fast Five so it's an
interesting turn when she shows up
scared bloodied and beaten at the steps
of Letty and Dom's humble abode they
surprisingly let her live because she
warns them about the incoming threat of
Dante in a flashback we see Dante
casually entering Cipher's secret
hideout to steal her Tech apparently on
his own she is unfazed at first until
all her trained security guards get
phone calls from their family members
who have been captured they then turn on
their former employer as Dante steals
her stuff and walks away Cipher then
tries to fight off all her guards at one
point she uses a large guard's body to
cushion her fall from a crashing
elevator what makes this scene stand out
though is how well it sets up Dante
flamboyant scary intelligent and
completely dismantle Cipher's operation
in one scene you know
do my best
after a botched mission in Rome lettius
captured and sent to an off-the-grid
agency prison she finds herself in
custody alongside Cipher who initially
helps Letty Escape Letty still
understandably hasn't let go of her
grudge against Cipher due to what she's
done to her and her family in the last
few movies this leads to an awesome
fight scene between the two in the midst
of their escape what really puts this
scene over the top is the introduction
of a laser robot in the middle of the
fight to be fair the robot is ostensibly
just a series of robotic appendages on a
crane that cauterizes wounds but during
the fight it becomes a ridiculous and
entirely fun obstacle that Letty and
Cipher have to dodge and weave around
Letty finishes the fight but eventually
comes back for Cipher's help when she
realizes the prison is in the middle of
Antarctica
after Jacob rescues Little Brian from
agency goons he and his nephew go on the
run the plan is for them to drive to an
airport and fly to a predetermined
Rendezvous Point Little Brian is
initially disappointed with Jacob's
seemingly janky car from the 90s with a
kayak on top but the two end up bonding
this includes a sequence where Jacob
shows Brian the wonders of Marky Mark
and the Funky bunches 1991 hit single
Good Vibrations even teaching the kids
some dance moves upon entering the
airport they are immediately caught on
camera by the agency but Jacob doesn't
seem too perturbed while on the plane
Jacob nonchalantly asks a flight
attendant for some alcohol which he
receives alongside a mysterious key he
then beckons Little Brian to the back of
the plane with him where he quickly
dispatches some agency goons in the
cargo hold Jacob unzips his kayak
revealing a miniature Batman style spy
glider which he quickly assembles then
he uses the alcohol as quick fuel to
help with their descent finally he uses
the mysterious key to open up the cargo
hatch and he and Brian fly out of the
747 in the glider its borderline
nonsensical and very cool
up to fast X the only seemingly
permanent death of a protagonist in the
series was that of Giselle yashar a
former associate in Mr nobody's agency
before joining the crew in 2009's Fast
and Furious she died sacrificing herself
to save her love interest Han in the
climactic mission to bring down Owen
Shaw the villain of Fast and Furious 6.
but like Han's death giselle's didn't
stick so I got my postcard out
after Cipher and Letty Escape their
prison they are still stranded on the
barren continent of Antarctica that is
until a giant nuclear submarine bursts
out from underneath the ice the top
hatch opens up to reveal an alive and
well Giselle it's the only time we see
her in the film but it raises so many
questions how did she survive where has
she been this whole time why is she
working for Cipher now and with so many
other plots and characters to service in
the remaining films will any of this get
explained
yes Han eats muffins laced with
hallucinogenic drugs and he trips out
for a scene it all starts once it's
revealed that Dante is using Cipher's
stolen Tech to digitally steal the
crew's immense wealth and pay for an
army of violent mercenaries luckily
Roman has stacks of cash so they look
for Black Market guns and vehicles to
buy fortunately the crew's resident
super hacker Ramsay knows about a secret
Black Market operation in London headed
by her former associate the Shady Bowie
the place they go to is a fake
storefront that deceptively seems to be
stuck in the 90s with old cream-colored
PCS with CRT monitors Ramsay points out
it's the last place the authorities
would look for a high-tech operation
later on Han finds Bowie has special
muffins sitting on his desk which he
casually helps himself to we then see
Han's POV colors and images swirling and
dancing it's reminiscent of a lot of
drug trips seen in movies but it's
shocking to see it happen so blatantly
in a fast and furious sequel
after Jacob's sacrifice Dom is chasing
down Dante and Little Brian in his
iconic black 1970 Dodge Charger RT
unfortunately for Dante Dom is
unaffected by nonsense like physics so
he's able to drive his car so that the
helicopter's Dante has sent to Harpoon
Dom's car crash into each other and
explode Dom then swings the tethered
helicopters like two giant medieval
flails that slam into Dante's muscle car
it's a nice call back to the tethered
Vault that originally brought down Dante
in the flashback this also gives Dom an
opportunity to speed up to Dante's car
and he gets Little Brian to jump into
his speeding charger just in time this
all culminates with dom and Little Brian
in the Dodge Charger trapped between two
speeding big rigs being driven remotely
by Dante on top of the Hoover Dam
There's No Escape except this is a fast
and furious movie so Dom decides to
literally drive down the side of the
Hoover Dam while out running the bill
Wing explosion from the crashed big rigs
fast X sort of Peaks early when Roman
leads a heist mission in Rome to steal a
dangerous microchip it all turns out to
be a trap set up by Dante when tej and
Ramsay get inside the truck that's
supposed to contain the chip it turns
out it's carrying a giant spherical bomb
instead Dante releases the bomb onto the
streets of Rome causing it to roll into
and Crush everything in its path at one
point the bomb crashes into a gas pump
creating a giant billowing explosion
Dante's plan is for the bomb to blow up
the Vatican what are we blowing up what
the Vatican wow you guys are going to
hell but Letty and Dom show up to save
the day Dom uses a crane to push the
bomb into the water even so the
explosion does a lot of damage and Dante
successfully gets the media to lay the
blame on Dom and his crew sending them
all underground what makes this scene so
great is all the little unique touches
such as Letty using her motorcycle to
jump over debris while chasing Dante
down and how the rolling bomb splits a
bus in two
[Music]